um
a few quick uh announcements if you've
been to our meetups before you've heard
all these announcements many times over
uh they're familiar but i see them
anyways because they're successful at uh
getting people to help us out
and these announcements are that we're
always sf data mining that that
organizes this along with trulia
uh i haven't happened to work for both
of them and um
we're always looking for people to help
organize we have a really cool set of
organizers you can come
uh work with us uh and um
you can you can help uh you can help
either organize events you can help just
identify speakers if that's something
interests you
um we're open to flying speakers in
these days as well
so if you have if you have a leads
contact so on um
that's great uh if you have venues and
you just want to contribute that way if
you
work for some company you think that
would be a great place
even if it's much smaller than trulia
much larger
even better but much smaller we have uh
we have certain topics which draws a
more niche crab
that we can actually other venues um
that's great come talk to me afterwards
we're also always looking for either
videographers
or sponsors for videographers so
we offer for sponsorship if you you know
cover the cost of videographers we'll
we'll put a slide in there that you know
says you sponsored and so on
get your needs that way um that's the
number one request we get from people
always
is for audio and video uh
tonight uh so we have obviously a couple
of speakers from linkedin our next
next scheduled meetup um looking after
october is also a speaker from
linkedin who um we'll be posting that
one in
within the next 24 hours um so i'll let
these guys introduce themselves and
we'll just get started
hi guys i'm vitaly i am a
senior data scientist here i
am going to talk about most of the work
that actually
is not me who's doing it and it's
patrick and
let him introduce himself and i'm
patrick i'm the crowd sourcing lead at
linkedin so i came in to basically build
a crowdsourcing center of excellence
there and make sure we're using it right
and using it in the right places
so we're going to go through a series of
projects talk about if we use
crowdsourcing and if so when
and if not why not
okay so let's see if this thing works
if not we're just going to use it
without it
yeah it works awesome okay so since it's
a kind of late hour for
everyone and you guys don't want to hear
us
just talk yeah we do
well tough luck so
we're not gonna talk about it we just
will basically do it as
this open discussion there are actually
not too many of you which is
great so um we will share um
a lot of uh interesting stories we face
with
data science and app linkedin and we
called it hacking data science because
hacking is an overused term data science
is overused term both of them together
are not so overused um and basically
it's
the things what do you think to make our
life as data scientists
easier and we'll present some use cases
we'll um ask you some questions you will
ask us some questions and hopefully
together we'll
learn something so um just
to kind of make it clear our we i didn't
hear a sketch of a very basic
uh kind of machine learning flow you
know
we gather some data we engineer features
we'll do the modeling evaluation
and we kind of circle it together
and we will um touch only some of the
points mostly gathering the data
and the evaluation and
i guess there were a lot of talks about
you know how to engineer feature
how to find the best model we won't
cover
this today we will only focus on the
first two
so let's start with our first story
which is a
understanding seniority which is
something that is kind of
valuable when we make 60 of our revenue
from our recruiting solution and you
know seniority is something that
we would like to understand and how to
do right
how to know that person x is for example
more senior than person y
or how senior each person acts
so let's look at the use case here is
one of my colleagues and for those of
you
you who don't see the small text
not very important what is kind of
i want to point here is daniel conkella
who one of the person will research and
he was managing the data science team
up until a couple of months ago and you
can see
spent most of his career as a chief
scientist at a company called
endeca and this company went to be
acquired by oracle for
a little bit more than one billion
dollar and
his next position after being a chief
scientist in the neca
which by then was a pretty large company
was a tech lead
of local search at google
so for us uh atlantean when we
look at the signal we try to understand
okay well
is attack with google is a more
senior position than achieve santa at
endeca
or maybe daniel was demoted and maybe he
didn't do his job very well and his next
job
wasn't as good as you can see after
becoming a tech
lead at google which is i guess it has
something already
daniel um have become a director of data
scientists
data science at linkedin which again
begs the question
uh is director of data science
is a more senior position than a tackle
that google and maybe also were
interested
to find out is kind of by transmitting
transitivity rules is director of data
science at google also more
senior than chief scientist and here's
kind of
my first question to you any ideas about
like
how can we infer whether heckley that
google is for example
is a more senior position than the chief
scientist at the neck off
or not yes
salary salary great
indicator and people move and
so one problem is also if you
can see that they will spend a lot of
time at the deck
and i have no idea what how his power
looks like but
it kind of affects and most people also
when they switch jobs they
get sell kind of higher compensation
just because
time went by and the market was good
enough
and but i guess the actual the more
serious problem about it that
linkedin doesn't have this data right so
we we don't know
um the per person salary it will be very
very
helpful for a lot of our data
products if you guys go all to linkedin
and somehow enter your salary
we can do a lot of amazing stuff with it
but we don't have this data
any other ideas applicants i have more
of a question and there's
a question of seniority within an
organization which is relative
and their seniority within the context
trajectory of a career
and then there's a notion of expertise
right which is that you're an expert
within a given domain
and i think these are different
questions you ask depending what kind of
what you're looking for
so let's see so that's a great comment
or
if i can paraphrase you say that
basically seniority or pretty much
everything else is also based on context
right what is the context that we're
asking for so in this context we can try
the following so
we see for example before um
let's say you're a recruiter at google
and you are now a want to hire a person
for a position of tech lead so um
we want to train our algorithms to also
suggest
the most relevant people for you and we
want to know that for example
chief scientists at companies like
indeca which is
can mean a lot of different things but
we want to suggest
these people also as a viable candidate
for and maybe a director of data science
until which is let's say a higher
seniority position
and then google maybe we don't and we
don't want to
uh suggest to you as a recruiter and if
you
are using linkedin you can you also
remember we have
jobs you may be interested a module and
we don't want to suggest for example for
a reference
application we don't want to suggest
tech lead roles
so in this context it's um kind of that
is why we need to understand it also
between companies
and not just within a certain company
yes they're yes yeah you can look at
other people
and see their trajectory as well i think
just looking at one person and
the labels over there is not going to
give you much information
i don't think you have enough on this
page but if you look at other people for
example at google
who are tech leads one thing that would
be helpful is looking at the internal
promotions
of two techniques so you can get some
sort of um
some sort of ordering first of all
within one company and then you might
want to look at other companies and see
the trajectory
of people other people who went into
google who are chief scientists
and see how they get promoted within
google to get a sense of delivery
and google at least you'll be able to
get a sense of relative seniority in
terms of how google views
chief scientists vis-a-vis for other
companies
you know some relative degree of the
same name the same title can be very
cool
okay so that's actually also a great
suggestion we can
look at many people that
had a similar position and to see how
their current trajectory
went and so kind of to go
fur our first our first problem that
companies like we said are not centered
tech lead and director
and chief scientist at every company
means
something else and also um one of the
problems with
this approach that not all of our um
for example tech lead local search if we
take this string as
is it probably will be a very very
sparse
position and we don't have too many
people that
have the exact same title to learn from
but let's look at the next example which
kind of makes
things even harder before working on
linkedin i was working at a company
called live person
and black person does this chat solution
but we have
two employees at five persons they work
and mark was a vice president of art
from technology's ecosystem
and idol was vp head of partner
ecosystem where
both titles actually sound very very
similar and the question here
is even within the same company
sometimes let's say
i'm looking to hire my next ceo and i
think i know
you know a live person is a great
company and i think i know
that the person i want to hire needs to
be a ceo but let's say
relatively senior ceo if sorry vice
president not a very
um junior vice president
so this is also kind of a problem that
um
we need to tackle that just titles
are not enough any idea about how can we
use
yes maybe seeing the projects that you
work with
you worked on similar projects that i'm
looking for
well even though i i kind of i agree
that
the project is a great indication in
hiring there are multiple but
i'm saying just in terms of seniority
let's say between zero and one um
don't forget about the content and use
the behavior towards these positions
when they're posted
uh like like for example when a tech
lead is posted at google
you get a sense of how much demand is
out there among people who have
other titles and so on mm-hmm yeah it
links into the competition so it's also
kind of a
one thing and there are kind of multiple
ways we
try to tackle and think about it and
just uh
there will be a lot of other questions i
i will get to ask so everyone will
hopefully get will get participate and
one of our data scientists
mario rodriguez actually came up with
what i think is pre-engineering solution
he actually
found that we have some of this
data and if you look here is the
recommendation that
um idol gave to mark
can you spot the key word this
recommendation
what is the word report exactly report
so now if we when we give recommendation
on linkedin we actually specify our
connection
to this person we say i don't remember
how many options but basically report
directly reported indirectly work
closely with
work with another company there are not
many but
they're pre-sara there are not too many
of them
and if we take the entire linkedin
recommendation we have
about a few millions of them and
we can actually start
using a kind of very nice
and build a very nice graph of people
that we know
are senior to another and kind of use a
pairwise comparison
algorithms to infer at least some
initial
labels at for uh how can we in for
seniority
and that's actually um
gave us kind of the first step of trying
to figure out
this problem which was uh very helpful
but
again if we go back to daniel and monica
we can see that here is a recommendation
that daniel gave to
monica gaddy and here it says
not so long ago that so you can see this
recommendation is fairly recent
so daniel managed monica at linkedin but
monica
meanwhile stopped working on linkedin
and actually got a new job where her
title is vice president of data
which kind of
screws up our
algorithms in the sense that we also
just need to pay
a lot of attention to how we build this
data and
deal with this data and not take things
so literally and kind of
try to get a snapshot of what
what were their titles at the exact
exact time where the recommendation
was given and presents kind of in
interesting
data challenges now that i won't worry
with but
i am i'm just saying even though we kind
of
found a cool solution for it still we
you know you know it doesn't solve
everything and we still need to
work around let's look at the kind of
second example
i want to go through and it's um
learning to target better
and as you can see that is kind of a
yeah an example where context matters
and one thing we also try to do
for all of you who have linked in the
profile you probably remember that you
never entered your gender
and but but we have your names and you
know we
say okay well can we use names to infer
your gender because for example for our
ad targeting stuff
we have customers that are interested in
this specific facet in order to do their
targeting um
any ideas about how can we infer
gender
all the text and recommendations he or
she
that's a great idea and actually that is
uh one of our data scientists for match
let's look again
at monica's recommendation by daniel you
will see
so pretty obvious monica is a she
well what kind of um
is it um
anyone knows who this is
wow really no one it's a beverly hills
9210 character her name was andrea
zuckerman maybe
i will have more luck with my second
guest
anyone knows who this is right and
rabuchelli
so probably figured out that both have
the same name
and when we look at so again
recommendation data is not enough we
need a little bit more context and
when ganesh ran his profiling on the
names from recommendation
he plotted them on the map and he got
this
very interesting graph as you can see
there are some countries especially
italy
when andrea is a male name and
not a female um
and we have again another guy
everyone knows who this is
and this one also her name is robin as
well
and here is how
robin apparently in most of the world
robin is a i think it's a female name
while in the united states is mostly
male name
and also we have this
sorry yeah i will speak to the
microphone
um so robin and
that is only one thing that we have this
geographical
problems with it and again
last i do you know the name of the actor
dana the name of this actor
stacy kitch yes so dana and stacy were
names that
historically at least were used by men i
don't think
anyone named naming boys well maybe dana
but
not a lot of space employees say more
and this is another problem
that again um kind of the point here
that i was trying to make is we need to
even though that we have some data that
can you know label us we need to kind of
treat those labels carefully but kind of
the larger
point here is the
the cheapest form of crowdsourcing is
actually no crowdsourcing
sometimes if you look kind of carefully
um
you can find the answer already knows
and sometimes it just
hides somewhere in your data and now
i'll wait
patrick to tell you a little bit more
about in cases where we actually
use crowdsourcing
awesome so the first lesson is if you
want to use crowdsourcing maybe you just
shouldn't maybe
look a little bit careful maybe you have
the data there but now we actually are
going to talk about
crowdsourcing um out of curiosity how
many people have actually used
mechanical turk
all right so few uh leave your hands up
how many people would say they were
successful in using mechanical turk
ish right it's good but it's kind of
hard
um so i'm going to go through a couple
of ways that you can use mechanical term
maybe more successfully a couple of best
practices of
places where we've used crowdsourcing
and how we got it to work
for this first example we're going to
talk about spam hopefully this is
fairly self-explanatory but we have
influencer content they're publishing
this
material shooting linkedin is a platform
for information exchange giving you the
the content that you need to be more
successful in your career
because that influencer content is
publicly visible it attracts
more of the spammers right so
clearly that's not a great thing it kind
of lowers the perceived value of
linkedin
and those people that are leaving these
comments are by and large linkedin
members
so we can't necessarily just ban them
outright
so how can we be a little bit more
clever about telling if a specific piece
of content is spam or not spam
we did have a bunch of already labeled
data
from previously identified spammers but
we wanted to be a little bit smarter
about it
so we took our existing classification
algorithm and sampled kind of along the
decision margin said all right we'll
train on those
uh but the first problem is that binary
tasks are kind of hard right
and they're hard in the sense that
they're actually way too easy um if
you've ever done this crowdsourcing you
may have had this problem but if the
question is just sort of yes or no is
this comment spam or not spam
there's not a huge difference between
someone who's doing really good work and
someone who's guessing
especially if they're only doing a
little bit of work right
so you need a little bit more of a
signal and the way you do that usually
is by
increasing the number of sort of
possible labels
so a lot of times that'll be is it spam
yes and
if so you know what kind of spam or no
uh so like yes if no but that kind of
thing
um second challenge is that it's kind of
hard to tell if something is spam right
so if you look at these
none of these are like amazingly high
quality comments right
nice sure this one
actually is totally relevant but if you
just read it in isolation you might not
know that
so we kind of figured well yeah you need
to know the original piece of content
but you also need to see a lot of these
pieces of content
uh together uh so hopefully this is kind
of an obvious lead up
that the way we designed this task was
just to do that right so we've
grouped a bunch of these comments
together
we provided the original source of
content and then we had people flag
any comment that was or was not spam
so far so good right except that we
still have an extremely biased data set
even when we're sampling where we think
there's a lot of spam you know best case
maybe it's 20
span probably is going to be a lot less
than that
so how do you calibrate a task to
maximize quality
has anyone done crowdsourcing do you
have any ideas
about sort of strategies you use to to
ensure quality
yeah some some plurality majority voting
system
that's definitely right that's sort of
the meat
of uh we'll call it one half of the meat
and then anyone else
maybe the other side in the back gold
labels yeah so gold labels and multiple
judgments is like the meat and potatoes
how you get your quality
um but okay what if
how do you set the distribution of gold
labels if you don't know what the
underlying distribution is of data in
your data set
if you think it's really biased so you
don't want people to be able to guess
their way through
how do you really differentiate between
good and bad workers
you know in general you want to have a
roughly even distribution of
items in your gold set in this case we
biased it pretty heavily towards spam
just because spam was so uncommon in the
set
um and then we got multiple uh judgments
on each item
and we treated any any comment that got
at least one vote
as kind of suspect if it got a plurality
of votes
great you know it was spam and then kind
of pipe those into another workflow
where we give them a second pass to make
sure
you are they really spam or they not
spam
um what are we using it for it's pretty
straightforward i think
other than there's no information there
but we're training a new
feature set or evaluating a new set of
features so how can we maximize
our recall without sacrificing too much
precision
and we added a bunch of features
variations testing it and using
crowdsourcing to
basically test uh which one of these new
implementations is going to work better
sort of a sense of scale we labeled you
know i think
around 20 000 comments for a few hundred
bucks
in 48 72 hours something like that
um so this stuff is really powerful if
you pick the right problems
and sort of approach it the right way
big takeaway here right is
think about the problem trying to solve
and sort of structure it in a way that
makes it help or easy for you to
actually get reasonable data back
out of the crowd anybody have any
questions about about spam before we
move on to the next little story
great so the next one is channels right
and if you've seen these on linkedin
hopefully you have we have
i don't know hundreds of channels now
and they're topics and we're trying to
find again
relevant content for you a linkedin user
so you come back you spend more time on
the site you
interact more and everyone's happy but
we need this to be timely we need it to
be relevant and we need to be relevant
across
many different topics so the team came
to the crowdsourcing
corner of linkedin and said all right
let's crowdsource this stuff we don't
know where to get these labels otherwise
and the first idea was all right we'll
just look at some articles we'll tag
them
with topics and we'll see what happens
now
you can probably guess if you've done
this at all the problem here is there's
a problem of consistency right
if we all read the same article we'll
probably come up with 20 different
topics
even if we're picking from a
standardized set of topics there's just
too many ways to interpret the main
point of this article and that is
expensive right because
crowdsourcing is inexpensive if you do
it right but it can the cost can add up
pretty fast
another alternative would be to set up
some complex multi-stage workflow where
you get some labels and you pass them to
another group
have them validated and have them ranked
and then i'm like yeah that would work
too but it was kind of more work than we
wanted to do
um so how do we get around this problem
um we actually have a pretty i think
interesting solution
and the team said why don't we just is
it well let's find a way to um
to suggest topics right so what topics
might be relevant for a specific article
at a most basic level i'm sure you guys
are kind of guess how this is going to
work but we trained a
sort of weak classifier to infer the
main topic
and in this one right machine learning
machine learning machine learning right
it's a pretty easy jump to say this
topic this article may be about machine
learning
and then because these were all skills
that we're using out of linkedin we can
use the skills data
so we have sort of co-occurrence of all
the different skills use that to expand
these query sets
and then essentially generated a set of
100 possible topics for each article
now this is actually pretty awesome
because what we can do at the end is say
all right here's an article here's a
topic
and then do sort of a very standard
relevance evaluation right
um i think in a later iteration of the
task we turned it to like
primary topic secondary topic and not at
all relevant
but using this data we can go back and
we can see which topics are relevant
which are not
and then eventually retrain on that data
to build these classifiers for these
hundreds of different channels
um this one consensus that was a big
point
and we were trying to think okay how do
we how do we get
it's a clean label uh gold you know
obviously you want to use gold all the
time
i mean this one we're thinking does it
make a lot of sense like if we have two
people saying
primary topic and two people saying
secondary topic
do we really want to resolve that
disagreement in the sense that well i
mean is that
in itself a useful enough signal we can
say that's a 2.5
um we decided it probably was so we
didn't do anything fancy with sort of
multiple judgments or variable judgments
or
confidence intervals we just said give
us four for each we'll use gold to
filter out a lot of the bad people
and see what quality looks like uh
quality looks pretty good but sort of
the next quality lesson here
sort of like not by gold alone um and so
this
is going to show worker accuracy on gold
on the bottom those are those
expert labels that you've created
in-house and then their agreement with
other workers
on the top if you look up here you kind
of see the shape that you would hope for
right
as they get better on gold they get
better
in agreement with other workers right
except for this little cloud of folk
down here in the bottom and they are
somehow
really bad on the items where we know
the answer are really good on the items
where we know the answer and really
bad compared to everyone else so maybe
they're really good and everyone else is
bad turned out in this case and in most
cases that's not what's going on
they've either learned gold or they
somehow identified how you're testing
them
and co-opted that so that is a problem
you can get around it by creating a lot
more gold gold creation is kind of
cumbersome people might say it's like
undoable the reality is you don't have
to do that much
maybe five or ten examples for each
class and then once you run a small set
you can bootstrap additional gold out of
there
right so you look at items that four or
five people looked at they all agreed
that this is highly relevant
great we'll use that as gold and spit it
out so someone says you know gold
creation is going to take me four hours
it defeats the whole purpose of
crowdsourcing
uh don't believe it basically the the
most time consuming part is
inevitably pulling the data out and then
analyzing it at the end
goal creation is sort of like debugging
right you're looking at individual rows
you might find out if we go back to this
task one thing we didn't know was that
even though we were only pulling uh
articles in english there were a lot of
articles that weren't in english right
we didn't know that until we looked at
individual items for evaluation
similarly there were a lot this is
actually not an article this is a job
description
we didn't know that those were getting
incorrectly tagged as articles
um and so it was that hour or two that
we spent creating gold by hand
that actually taught us like this is the
way that your data is not what you
expect it to be
and that is actually immensely valuable
the same way you're going to test your
code
and debug your code think of digging
gold as
that debugging process again what do we
use it for
this is evaluating our existing
classification framework
there's a paper that'll come out
hopefully soon where the engineers talk
about all the very clever ways they use
to
extend this across all the other topics
here needless to say it's very clever
it's very over my head but it seems like
it works really well
um the big takeaway here i think is is
be helpful right
help your helpers and think about again
like what's a task that someone could
agree on
or a lot of people could agree on
particularly with a very minimal spin-up
time
and if you can get your tasks sort of
into that realm
you'll have a lot more success and a lot
less pain
any questions about channels classifiers
and
helping helpers
all right so we'll do one more this is
about search um
linkedin search as you can imagine major
affordable information on the site
it helps you find people it helps you be
found by people
you search for people you search for
jobs you search for groups content
it's sort of this very holistic way of
tying together all
parts of the site and giving you
information that's relevant to you which
is sort of the core value of linkedin
right
i want you to go there to improve your
career
i'm challenged with that especially with
people right as it is highly
personalized
so if i search for architect i might get
you know the guy who built my house and
tell him i get the guy who's a software
software engineer architect um similarly
kevin scott
uh vp of engineering at linkedin is only
one of many kevin scotts that are on
linkedin with profiles and they're
all within one degree of separation from
me
so how do we pick them on that for a
highly personalized search
um usually traditionally when you're
doing search relevance evaluation
you can use crowdsourcing and it works
pretty well you can imagine if you're
looking at ebay search results and i say
i search for ipad mini and i got an ipad
mini case
doesn't take a whole lot of sort of
cognitive weight
to say that's probably not quite right
um
there are more complicated cases maybe
you're looking for like car parts
and it's kind of esoteric stuff but it
can be done in this case it's really a
tuple right there's a user
there's a query and there's a document
so can i really ask you to say okay
pretend that you're
a linkedin employee you're searching for
this name
it's not gonna work even if you sort of
abstract at a level and say all right
pretend you're a plumber
and you search for antique pipe
installation are you really going to be
able to differentiate between the
different people that come up
maybe maybe not right so the very
fine-grained relevance that you usually
use for this with ndcg scores and all
that
kind of falls apart with this highly
personalized search
so what do we do we train from the logs
and that works pretty well
but we can still do some evaluation
there's a number of measures that we use
is click through rate at one right just
click through on page one
you can look at session abandonment um
but what about explicit relevance
measures the things that you know google
has an army of people doing and amazon
sort of invented mechanical turk to do
how do we do that with crowdsourcing
anybody have
any ideas of ways that we could try to
measure explicitly the relevance of
search
somebody's got to have one idea
that's right no it's wtf at one right um
so we said all right well let's take
some very
unpersonalized results in the sense that
we're not going to ask you if it's
somewhat relevant highly relevant
extremely relevant or perfect
we just want to know if it's like
totally wrong right
so we looked at we sampled among these
queries where there was no click on the
first
result to be you know we actually don't
care if like we're getting good results
most of the time we want to know where
we're not getting good results
and get some running measure of that so
queries where number one didn't get a
click and then made sure they weren't
like first name last name queries
that completely match the profile
so within this subset looking at these
queries that we think might not perform
that well
and then we also did again sort of
expanding beyond a simple binary task
we're kind of tagging what kind of query
it was right so is it jobs at a company
that's helpful because we have a whole
query understanding uh infrastructure
that
puts tags on these queries so we can get
kind of a two-for-one
audit and it really just gives us this
explicit relevance measure that we can
look at over time
so is this wtf rate is it going up is it
going down
and then we can sort of dig into the
ones where we see that this is
completely wrong and see what's going on
it's actually helped us identify the
kinds of ways that these queries go
wrong
and hopefully help us to put together a
solution
um so another way of doing quality with
crowdsourcing you have gold you have
agreement you have redundancy
but there's also a whole another
category of behavioral metrics this is a
very simple one but it's looking on the
x
sort of how long it took you to do a
task and on the why
sort of how often you agreed with the
aggregate answer at that task
i was actually shocked when i saw it
cited it sort of goes with what your
intuition would be but that doesn't
always work
but as they're going really fast the
quality is pretty lousy
and then as it moves up it eventually
stables off and the stuff out at the end
is just noise
but if you look at the the volume tab
under here right you can see that
there's
some subset of people that are going
really fast
and they're just doing like terrible
work so you can use that to
probably set a minimum task time but you
can think of a bunch of other behavioral
metrics that you could look at right so
judgment duration but you could also
look at scrolls and clicks
you could look at um sort of the time
spread between judgments are they always
taking
between four and a half and five and a
half seconds or do they have some at two
and some at nine
so trying to identify these bots
different kind of workers might fall
into
um so yeah that's you know jquery you
can actually do a lot of this stuff
without a whole lot of uh technical
ability
meaning that i can actually do it but
the takeaway here right is like
pick a solvable problem um so don't ask
someone to do something that
for example you couldn't do within your
team and we have a lot of examples of
these that we may or may not
get into but it's like if if you can't
explain to me
how to do it or if you can't expect the
five people on the search team to come
to the same
answer it's not a crowdsourceable
problem it's actually not a solvable
problem
um so reset think about what's going on
right
and can you find a parallel problem
that's actually solvable and relatively
straightforward and
focus your efforts on that another cool
takeaway on this one we ran this
internally and externally
so within the linkedin search team and
with sort of the crowdsourcing world at
large
and results were nearly identical and to
the extent that we
could see differences it seemed to be
fewer false positives with the
crowdsourcing
workers so a lot faster it's a lot less
annoying
and it seemed to be if not more accurate
at least as
accurate um so this sort of takeaway
here right is also
if you hear someone complaining about
how crowdsourcing doesn't work it didn't
work for me whatever that you know it
just doesn't work
like backup if your code doesn't work it
might not be
the language right it may be uh
something that you've done
so you can get good quality out of
crowdsourcing but you have to do
sort of these few sort of simple tips
and tricks
um before we send it back to the tally
for some more of these
non-crowdsourcing examples any questions
about
gold or agreement or sort of behavioral
metrics and
multiple judgments and these different
schemes of managing quality for
anonymous distributed workers
yeah with seniority and with gender we
started the conversation with
with crowdsourcing and yeah i mean we
could have looked at pictures but
not everyone has a picture so there were
some limitations there
and with seniority it was like well how
do we want to measure do you want to put
it in buckets and say you know there's
five levels or there are three levels or
there are ten levels
or do this pairwise evaluation and as we
were kind of debating about what's the
best way to do this
somebody realized that actually we have
this data so
let's train on that uh on the
recommendations data and then we
evaluated it with
crowdsourcing as sort of a large scale
audit and it looked really good
and uh google that was my gender
or is that why they have google plus to
get your conversation
yeah i couldn't tell you how they do it
but if they they could probably tell a
lot from your gmail and your google plus
and
everything else but actually how they do
that i don't know
to do the crowd sourcing so we use
crowdflower at full disclosure i've
worked at craftwire before linkedin but
we essentially licensed the platform
so we don't have to build these sort of
basic things but we don't build gold we
just
use their evaluation gold set multiple
judgments that's all built in
not all of it you know the behavioral
stuff we do on top a lot of the
agreement stuff we do on top
but sort of the basic infrastructure of
crowdsourcing we just
licensed it because frankly it wasn't
worth our time to to build it from
scratch it's going to be way more
expensive
did you have a question yeah
since all the examples
like people had to fill in their
linkedin profiles what's the percentage
yeah sparse profiles are are definitely
a challenge i think
we talk about that in the uh in the next
example so i'll
pump that one to the tally but you know
definitely there's
there's problems with crowdsourcing if
the profile doesn't have any information
in it
and in the beginning we talked a little
bit about seniority you know people with
you know very limited profiles
but by looking at other information
about them we could infer stuff that
wasn't in the profile explicitly
and tell us of how senior they were
any examples where crowdsourcing didn't
work where you thought it would
oh yeah i mean a lot of these didn't
work the first time we did a big project
if finding um sort of seo spam profile
spam
and that one was really challenging for
a number of reasons i mean the spammers
are good at what they do right so they
didn't want to be caught by the linkedin
admins so they hid their seo spam in
in clever and interesting ways that we
actually can't talk about because
we don't want them to know that we know
um
yeah but i mean those are really fun
right when you have this adversarial
relationship between the task you want
to do
and the data you have to work with so it
is sort of a cat and mouse game and
we do stuff and they do stuff and yep
and the thing that surprised me was
there was this min cut max flow
which from back in the day i remember
that that's used for
finding a maximum flow through a
generalized transport network
good question uh no clue that was
basically
the different methods that the relevance
guys were using
to take those labels and infer sort of
more information beyond that
but i don't know if that is the same
algorithm that you're talking about
did you have to train your workers
before you let them into the system
yeah that's another thing that we just
licensed from crawfire so we use gold to
do basically an upfront task
so you have to establish that you're
over some threshold of accuracy
on those gold labels and then once you
do we let you in
and we track you sort of in real time on
every some selection of judgments that
you submit
we're testing you with gold and with
these agreement and other metrics
but essentially we've built in that
upfront training and we
at this point haven't had to go down the
route of building a specialized crowd of
people
um it's really nice if you don't have to
do that because you get all this sort of
flexibility of
we have a new task and it's not like any
other task and we want it done soon
so rather than building out some perfect
crowd of people we just have
these quality control metrics that work
pretty well in near real time
to filter good people from bad people
uh yeah here in the middle uh
is interesting it it tends to be sort of
iterative and sort of
magical that some of it depends on what
overall volume there is in the system
in like the entire crowdsourcing
marketplace so for some reason
you know you're coming up on someone
else who's got a whole lot of data you
may have to pay a little bit more
um but you really you're balancing when
you need it by
i mean that's the main lever um quality
is interesting
if you do all your quality control right
there shouldn't be too much of a
difference in quality
meaning that we haven't systematically
been able to recreate quality
differences based on pay
as long as you're not paying too little
and if you pay a lot you tend to attract
the
most motivated and nefarious
crowdsourcing guys
so you know you don't want to pay like
10 bucks a hit either
um there's one in the back and then
let's give it to vitali and we can pick
it up
okay yeah that's good question um so
let's give it back to the tally
hey well it was a long slide to kind of
look at
without a contest and this is actually
an
extra form um a linkedin guide
to tours about how to use our search
under
various boolean queries there
and here is the part that explains how
to you know
do or in order to solve a specific
problem
and and you can see that's the kind of
smart test i guess recruiter on your
platform know that
people people use different titles
that basically mean the same things and
for me as
a data scientist it kind of makes me sad
to see actually that people need to go
and write this
boolean or queries in order to get
um to found
what they need basically that sells
executive and account executive
are are the same and
so we had a special project that we also
said okay well let's stop uh
recruiting using this um his methods
because we definitely can
help them in order and standardize our
titles um any ideas about how
one can go about it how can we
standardize titles basically
infer that yeah account executive and
sales
executive are the same people an account
executive
et cetera
synonym as in
like a compiled list of uh synonyms
yeah that's one thing
like you have vp period
yeah but how do we know that it's the
same one
um
that's true there
linkedin is a network you could leverage
people's closed connections as
colleagues
that's true we can you know
people tend to flock with people or with
similar titles
and definitely anyone else
basically using sessions as an
indication that the person
uh search session is an indication that
the user was
using the same looking for the same
a good ux trick is when they're
inputting their profile through type
ahead
like so provoke them to type vp count
executives
versus a shortcut that's true and that
is actually a good point on a
broader subject that i forgot to mention
that um
crowdsourcing in data and data science
go hang
hand in hand as you know a complementary
solution to make an offering better
but design is definitely also one of
them if we design our
interface right and you know all of our
jobs it will be easier and for example
today we have type ahead for the um
what users enter to the profile in the
first place and not only in search and
that encourages them to use actually
standardized data and
not to try to type something else on uh
of course it not always works some
people just want to be called
account execs right but at least we
make it easier for us um was there a
idea
two different two different people that
were hired to the same role
um how
do i know they were hired for the same
role
well tracking their history over time
okay
so yeah we can look at people that have
a similar history
and we also have a yes
maybe also the job descriptions uh job
seekers and
thinking through uh job descriptions
that have slightly different positioning
names
that's true yeah we can also use
javascript and we can actually use a lot
of data
for example we have skills we can for
the similar skills and
networks and a lot of basically it's a
pile of
features but because since it's a kind
of crowdsourcing part
we also try to crowdsource this
information okay
and to your previous question about
um was there a werder a crowdsourcing
task that didn't go well
so i can say that the same as with
modeling
probably the first iteration of any of
our tests did not go
as well as we should and the same as
with modeling we try to apply one model
see
what doesn't work and try to improve it
the same was here so
kind of that is what we tried um
we first tried um the first question
and it was kind of hard right because
especially if you get let's say
professions from you know
medical uh industry or um
law or something like that and then we
ask a completely random person
okay you know what's a kind of super
title name for this title
and you know and
we just didn't get a
very good result the second question is
as you can all see
is actually much much simpler and
here is also we kind of going back to
the
lessons that were mentioned by patrick
as well we did some legwork here so
our data scientists say ahmed she
he worked out basically some
unsupervised learning he
first clustered all the titles
using all the metrics you you just
mentioned and
then um kind of did the
title similarity and found the mean
title of
every cluster and then use it to
extract what can be a potential
candidate for
the name of that cluster so for the
example before it can be
an account executive or a sales
executive just
which whichever one is more common
and we use that as a proposal
for our turkers and now it became from
just labeling it's actually started to
become an
evaluation but with some uh again given
we spent some time on it but we've got
an order of magnets better results than
our
uh first iteration and kind of
again it's keep it simple um
so our final example before we finish
will be
um something that we also do
ranking skills is kind of a joke from
the internet about
uh who is the person who uh
you know the best at basketball and
let me show you the first uh the first
attempt
so for those of you who don't know we
have a skills page that you can go
and on the skills page you can see
skills and patrick mentioned the
related skills and you can see also like
the top 10 or top 20 people
at that skill where they work which
geography
are are they in and we basically try to
learn
um for this so here is
our first attempt at skill breaking so
we gave our crowdsourcing
this is actually ahmed's profile a guy
from the
title standardization and we try to say
okay
how good ahmed is at being a data
scientist
or being in you know a data mining
special or machine learning
and again to be honest i think the first
time we
probably set up a task that
was not really um not
not only it wasn't suitable for crowd
sourcing it's actually
i really don't know how to answer that
right if we give you a scale from one to
ten
and by discounting so on well granted
they also had education
you can see it here and maybe some skill
data it's very very hard to answer
and this question okay how good this
person is
at a certain scale so we try
you know we have a lot of smart guys
working for us so
um you know we realize that something is
wrong here
so we did a second attempt and here we
actually compare
again the same data science to another
data scientist that is working uh
at the linkedin team and now we ask okay
and
for those of you who've seen the um
social network movie it's like the
hotter hot or not or
for data scientists and which one
is better the right or the left one
and again um knowing both of these
people
and working working with them closely
i still find it hard to answer this
question
because um you know there's multiple
ways to define what is be
being good at data science means right
and especially when we now take a person
that
doesn't know these people and
also not necessarily they design this
it's really not a lot of information
to actually answer this question
so our third update will say well we
know some people who are good at some
stuff
and here is um you know i
like the programming language scholar
very much
you can see the sticker on my laptop and
martin lutherski is the creator of scala
so we can say okay well maybe we can use
this person as
you know our baseline for to evaluate
people who are good
at something which is for example scala
but
um the problem is it's very hard to
actually generate
a very extensive data set for people who
are good
at something and if i have uh martin
luther king first call and i take some
people who wrote book
in that scholar or maybe are active in
the community or
somehow generate a list for every skill
i'm afraid that
i'm um kind of i might get
the problem that you know my classifier
will tell me that
epfl professors are very good at scala
which is something that definitely can
happen by having a
only one so um and again to kind of
re paraphrase the question that uh
ask it's um i assume most of you
here are data mining people and you
definitely work
with other data mining people so when
you
think about comparing two of your peers
to each other
it's not easy to answer okay what what
is the
feature i'm looking for and probably
there is no
one single feature and that is why it's
not a very
a good question just to ask but
any ideas about like how how is it
possible to solve
that question about like who are the
best people
um college degree
that might be a factor yeah it says the
first
education right
communication skills perhaps a lot of
but how how would i kind of come up with
the weights
right because i need to train against
some label
set in order to come up and
here they're very similar very similar
so for example i find the similar
crowdsourcing expert
patrick and what do i do so you know
it's almost like when you take too big
of a data set you're trying to compare
apples and artists you know like
these different names you try to find
titles of
different positions and stuff if you
find somebody who has something very
similar and you can somehow find
differences
so just for these of you who do not hear
if anderson correctly is
finding people who are kind of close
enough to each other that it will be
much easier to to compare than my
you know any other recruiter decide
what's important
because i might
well that's that's true about um
um kind of we can use some
type of tweaking but i assume and again
this list
probably if we are going to ask everyone
in the audience and
you know everyone will have it will have
a different answer
about it so um there was actually was a
startup i don't know exactly what
happened with it that
did a kind of cool thing on top of
linkedin
api i think the name was mixten that
they actually
gave you two of your friend connections
too and you chose between them uh
regarding a certain skill so they ask
you
you know is your friend
x better than your friend y at some
sort of skill and then when they have
had a lot of
pairwise comparison they kind of used it
in order to generate some ranking for
you
between your friends and it was also
kind of gamification aspect of it which
is
i have no idea how accurate their data
was but at least as a product it was
kind of fun for people to use and i
think they
they were mostly using it to kind of
drink your
linkedin profile by just giving the
um you a game to play but um
i think we try and we
the examples i've uh tried to illustrate
were actually
um examples where we tried crowdsourcing
and
and it didn't work as well as we thought
and kind of when we thought about it the
second time we realized
okay maybe the task was just not right
and crowdsourcing is not
you know a magic solution that finally
that suddenly gives you kind of
a magic um labels and you just
you know everything needs left is just
applying your a classification model
so our kind of final thing is you know
more bad data does not equal
better data so it's not that if
you get more labels suddenly and
the classifier the classifiers will
start to perform better and what's
actually
the worst thing about the label
generation phase
is there is no way to know it with my
with modeling techniques
we can pretty much know with holdout set
you know how accurate our model is
but if we got it wrong uh during the
labeling then you know we can have a
perfect
model that just tells us nothing so
since we're
kind of running out of time and everyone
started and want to go home
i will just summarize the main lesson
that we learned
doing crowdsourcing tasks at linkedin
is the first one is again try to use the
data you already have
in most cases we can find something that
is somewhat somewhat correlated to the
problem we are trying so
second one is again keep it simple the
workers are
not people that will do all the work for
you
so try to do something like at the very
least try to give them a problem that
you would be able to solve yourself
and again that's free help your helpers
is sometimes especially we
as a data scientist need to do some leg
work
in order to make this task and
kind of when we look at the entire kind
of
total cost of the project it's actually
much more worthwhile to do some
of the preliminary work in all identical
sources and try to crowd
crowdsource it first and
we're very lucky to have patrick and our
team that has
a lot of experience in telling us what
what
would work what's not but in most cases
it just you can apply
logic um can assemble intelligently is
this
is basically don't give them you know
the entire
data set of possible outcomes it goes
back to the same point and the last
i mentioned more bit data does not equal
any better data
um that's all for us and
we can have last question just before
the question phase in order
you know for patrick and i um to
be able to say that we did our job right
we just want to mention that linkedin is
hiring
hurry everyone at anyone
is like every position i don't care
who you are what you do we're probably
hiring in
in that position so just say please
connect with me or patrick on linkedin
better with me so i can get the bonus
but
and just shoot us an email and we'll
pass it through
yes questions for me or patrick so what
did you end up doing for the seniority
um so we we started with the
recommendation as a kind of bootstrap
in order to bootstrap the learning phase
and then we
gave it to the cat the turkers to act
kind of multiple choice we gave them is
this person and
multiple lists of seniorities because
one of the problems with seniority that
we didn't touch here is sometimes people
have
multiple profiles but basically
we used both both are
kind of inferred seniority based on the
recommendation graph
and also the answer given by the turkish
i really want to
say anything else about it i think it's
pretty accurate
yeah other questions
yes practical question how do you guys
decide how much is okay to spend on
crowdsourcing for a particular project
well i can tell you my view is uh
since patrick is doing all the work so
you know the longer the better
and but it's better the real answer is
that
the amount you spend on crowdsourcing is
a small piece
it may not even be compared to the
amount of time that you have your
team of data scientists working with
this data set you spend
you know 500 bucks even a thousand bucks
on the crowdsourcing it's like
it's a drop in the bucket compared to
the amount of time that uh
your team is actually using
are you exploring something like um this
person is likely a good
customer or a good prospect is there
some way to
use these techniques for that the
question is if we're looking at
are people a good customer a good
customer for me for you for
yeah that feels like a hard problem um
because yeah no i hate hard problems
easy ones
i know so once upon a time i tried to
sell crowdsourcing and
every customer is a unique snowflake
that looks different and needs different
things
and maybe crowdsourcing is special but
um i don't know that we have anything
like that in the pipeline
but you should join us and build it
and there's i guess an area about
matching students up with
universities and other educational kind
of opportunities
uh what kind of like data elements are
you guys
you know looking to collect for uh
students like you know how are you gonna
tackle that problem to
find the right fits
yeah it's actually a part of my team
works on the
our higher education stuff um so we have
uh like you talk first example is
kind of school standardization because
we
need to know what schools there are you
know one can write stanford university
they are
stanford and basically at the very basic
level is the
data cleaning operation of understanding
and also understanding that
the gsb and center for
somehow related on top of that we also
for
students that want to kind of find where
to go to school we have
similar schools the same way we have
similar profiles small jobs so if you're
interested again in stanford we can say
okay berkeley and ucla for example
it can be also bible school and we can
uh we also try to do it not
just you know on a very top level school
but also based on your field of study
so if you want to go to in engineering
then the schools are
that are similar to stanford are
different than if you want to learn
medicine and
um what other notable notable alumni
i i am i don't know if you saw but that
was
also a project we did you can go to your
school now and you can see where the
notable alumni is did we use
crowdsourcing
we did we so we actually use
crowdsourcing to understand who are
the noble alumni and we will be we have
kind of large part data science team
working
on this new initiative
i'm sure you have a large percentage of
your group is made up of software
engineers
and managers and others what percentage
do you think is made up of people with
degrees that neither psychology or
social science
um wow it's a
it's a great question i i think today
the data science team at length is i
think
a little bit more than 50 people
and unfortunately i don't know all of
them
and but i think we have one or
two that come from this background and
the person who runs our actual business
analytics
group also are called data scientists he
actually was a
brain surgeon and he decided to convert
to a data scientist i think the story
behind it is
he found out that what he likes best
about brain surgery is actually the data
aspect of it
and so he just decided to do it full
time and without cutting people
yeah so we're
again i think we're open and we're
definitely starting hiring more
people that come from physics background
there is some level of statistics that
is necessary to be able to perform the
job but we're definitely
interested in exploring kind of new
professions and field of studies to make
our team more diverse
and that i have a social science degree
and the director of the data science
group is an econ guy too
so yeah so there are people they're not
all computer scientists like natalie
no no one's
about perfect it's possible to be
successful
uh going into data science if you don't
have
uh like a mathematics background you
didn't if you didn't go to school for
math he's
you know it's impossible to even bring
into that field
if you can convince someone you're a
crowdsourcing expert you can't
um well it's hard to say
so a lot of our people are not math
majors but they're kind of computer
science but so there is some element of
math just because it's kind of related
to computer science and not just because
we're looking for
plain plain maps so there are a lot of
you know statistical
elements to our job but to be honest
uh we are we don't really care now
at our harboring stage exactly what you
did at school because
you know there are better better signals
to do and
if someone for example you know has a
done great stuff elsewhere and we have
people that we hired because they did
some awesome visualizations
and you know they were or are data
scientists
at linkedin so basically if you can do
neat stuff with data we don't really
care what
you went to school for
yes
yeah i think the question is about sort
of career paths right yes
it gets back to that standardization
problem title standardization i mean
yeah
fields of study of relatively
standardized but to track someone's
or compare paths through a career across
a lot of different people um
i think the big challenge there is is
standardizing titles to know that
you know a senior software developer is
not that different from a
software engineer to and those sorts of
problems
i think that was your question i think
we kind of punted it because we haven't
standardized the titles well enough to
uh to do that yet
yeah i i think i can also add then again
that
might sound a little bit pretty but we
do believe in it and a lot of
the people that work on linkedin so
linkedin's mission is like to
become the career portal uh you know for
everyone so we believe that you should
go to linkedin for
anything that related to your career and
our influencer
stuff was you know a big part of it so
yeah
we're definitely thinking about you know
how it
to be more to have more and more
opportunities
a lot of them are using beta products in
order to kind of make
people to help people make
better choices in their career is
just we haven't reached uh you know the
full
capabilities and potential of what we
can do
definitely we're thinking about it maybe
i'm kind of missing something but it
seems
like um the issue of titles like once
you
like regex and replace vp with you know
vice president you do simple stuff like
that it wouldn't seem to be more than a
few tens of thousands
of variations or unique titles
um wouldn't it be simpler to just
straight over tackle just build a
big taxonomy of titles you know in for
every country say or
you know something like that and then
just apply that to all profiles so
just kind of curiosity how how many
different titles you think linkedin data
sets have how many unique titles
well i mean yeah it's about three orders
of magazines
more in linkedin we have if i'm not
well correct me if i'm wrong 17 000
different names for the company
ibm 17
000 people have managed to enter a
unique
name for the company a company that has
three letters
in it and
so it's so actually our first
our first title standardization effort
that we call
title standardization v1 was actually
generate the
in ontology of titles and using regular
expressions
and that was kind of um carrying us so
far
but we have again if i'm not going to
say
tens of millions of different titles so
and
yeah this um
regix approach i think
cover gives us coverage of
about 20 of them unfortunately
us yes so these these conversions
it sounds like you're machine out
machine learning algorithms are using
them but
you actually go back and provoke the
author to say please
change your title to do this because
that'll help users like if i see
three versions of ep as a human if i
kept seeing a consistent approach like
your machines are getting a luxury to
see
i might do a better job myself
so we are not updating profiles for
users
um but definitely you know each time you
enter a new position then we will try to
do our best in order to
you know to make you feel uh standardize
the title
and you write that maybe kind of in a
cognitive sense
people after have being on one platform
and seeing the same title over and over
again
but you know for example um i know if
anyone work here at yahoo there's this
member of the technical
sorry technical yahoo or some companies
you know just call himself member of the
technical staff
and there is just some culture that is
probably
you won't be able to change just by
having other people
uh write different names for the same
title
most of uh linkedin market
this in the us maybe countries that
speak english but the problem is that
what i saw is that
when titles actually was written in a
different language than english
when people come by linkedin they
basically
i'm not sure if they actually come up
with a title that they like
or so did you face kind of problems when
the actual title
not in english so is the question is
if someone let's say uses the french
version of linkedin
and wants to input an english title
so actually if i'm not mistaken we allow
for two versions of your entire profile
am i right so you can you can have a
profile in two different
languages your original language and an
english profile and we will
do the matching so you can so if a
person speaks english he will see your
english title and
if he speaks french for example he will
or not speaks french basically using the
french version of linkedin we'll see the
french page of your profile
okay well thank you guys